hey guys I'm Lucy and I'm tomorrow we're
here games come 2016 to try something a
little bit different for South Park the
fractured but whole and it's also kind
of terrifying yeah
we're genuinely nervous about it yeah so
it's a nosey this rift which ties into
South Park fractured back with pothole
there's a mechanic where you fall to
interact with your surroundings or just
for funsies just like in real life yeah
are you doing real life and this knows
ulis rift device it transfers the smell
of that fart directly into your nostrils
so they've had like proper perfume
designers designers you have to create
actual alchemists create this horrible
odor from within your bum is called fart
number three
yeah so god knows what Oh - part 1 & 2
were like yeah um but let's um let's
little bit we've got this spray just in
case things get really escort emergency
spray emergency spray yeah so you're not
all right it's not in the gameplay we're
in the kitchen I don't see I'm in
control of when I fought so it's up to
me - all right I'm gonna do one now oh
my god that is disgusting oh that's it
oh that is gross I'm good tiding it
oh this is like where those videos you
see on YouTube but people just try and
make yourself sick oh alright I might
throw up a bit whose job is it to make
it why would you make this this is such
a bad idea
okay well I'm in the bathroom and you
can poop um oh I've been called to try
this oh so you have to what is it like
Greece and then spread the Chi my eyes
watering now I'm gonna do one more fall
I should not have done the same for I
should not have done that last one or
I'm done with this any pressure that is
gross that is disgusting hey don't ever
want to play this game again